[bell rings]
- ALL RIGHT, LISTEN UP, Y'ALL.
I'M Y'ALL'S SUBSTITUTE TEACHER,
MR. GARVEY.
I TAUGHT SCHOOL FOR 20 YEARS
IN THE INNER CITY,
SO DON'T EVEN THINK
ABOUT MESSING WITH ME.
Y'ALL FEEL ME?
- MM-HMM.
- OKAY.
LET'S TAKE ROLL HERE.
JAY QUELLIN.
WHERE'S JAY QUELLIN AT?
NO JAY QUELLIN HERE?
- [clears throat]
- YEAH.
- UH, DO YOU MEAN JACQUELINE?
- OKAY. SO THAT'S
HOW IT'S GONNA BE.
Y'ALL WANNA PLAY.
OKAY, THEN.
I GOT MY EYE ON YOU,
JAY QUELLIN.
BALAKAY.
WHERE IS BALAKAY AT?
THERE'S NO BALAKAY HERE TODAY?
YES, SIR.
- MY NAME IS BLAKE.
- BL...
ARE YOU OUT
OF YOUR GODDAMN MIND?
[mocking voice] BLAKE.
WHAT?
DO YOU WANNA GO TO WAR, BALAKEY?
- NO.
- 'CAUSE WE COULD GO TO WAR.
- I'M FOR REAL.
I'M FOR REAL.
SO YOU BETTER CHECK YOURSELF.
DEE-NICE.
IS THERE A DEE-NICE?
IF ONE OF Y'ALL SAYS
SOME SILLY-ASS NAME...
THIS WHOLE CLASS
IS GONNA FEEL MY WRATH.
NOW, DEE-NICE.
- DO YOU MEAN DENISE?
- SON OF A BITCH!
YOU SAY YOUR NAME RIGHT,
RIGHT NOW.
- DENISE?
- YOU SAY IT RIGHT.
- DENISE.
- CORRECTLY.
- RIGHT.
- DENISE.
- DEE-NICE.
- THAT'S BETTER.
- [sighs]
- THANK YOU.
NOW, AY-AY-RON.
WHERE ARE YOU?
WHERE IS AY-AY-RON RIGHT NOW?
NO AY-AY RON, HUH?
WELL, YOU BETTER BE SICK,
DEAD, OR MUTE, AY-AY-RON!
- HERE.
OH, MAN.
- WHY DIDN'T YOU ANSWER ME
THE FIRST TIME I SAID IT, HUH?
- HUH?
- YOU KNOW, I'M JUST ASKING YOU.
I SAID IT,
LIKE, FOUR TIMES.
SO WHY DIDN'T YOU SAY IT THE
FIRST TIME I SAID, "AY-AY-RON?"
- BECAUSE IT'S PRONOUNCED
"AARON."
- SON OF A BITCH!
[clattering]
YOU DONE MESSED UP, AY-AY RON,
NOW TAKE YOUR ASS ON DOWN
TO OH-SHAG-HENNESY'S OFFICE
RIGHT NOW AND TELL HIM
EXACTLY WHAT YOU DID!
- WHO?
- OH-SHAG-HENNESY!
- PRINCIPAL O'SHAUGHNESSY?
- GET OUT OF MY GODDAMN
CLASSROOM BEFORE I BREAK
MY FOOT OFF
IN YOUR ASS!
INSUBORDINATE...
AND CHURLISH.
TYM-OH-THEE.
- PRESENT.
- THANK YOU!